It's more likely that we would extract all the
author data from documents such as these. How would we
do that? Assuming this document was illustrative of the entire
biomed central schema, write a program that will use the
element tree module to extract all the data for
a given research article. The data for each author should
be stored in a python dictionary, and all the dictionaries
should be stored in a list. By all the author
data, I mean all of the values stored here for each
one of the author tags in the author group that is part
of the front matter section. Now this is a lot like what
we did with CSV files, building python dictionaries to represent the data
we're extracting from, in this case XML files. Now, one thing to
keep in mind as you're doing this is that this is a
lot like what we did with CSV data, building python dictionaries to
represent the data we are extracting from. In this case XML files.
One final point here is that you may ignore the
INSR tags, simply leave them out of your data processing